it's not just our political leaders and
it's not just these i don't want to call
these people leaders it's not just these
awful politicians who want to destr who
want to lie to you or destroy the
constitution and destroy the country and
it's not just the media that
occasionally gets some things right it's
also our corporations the corporations
have gone all in on this woke nonsense
as you know and uh now when i'm i grew
up on the island okay now on long island
there's a tradition of good pizza we
have good pizza the idea that you would
go to pizza hut let's say in long island
is crazy you would never go to a chain
right you go to mario's you go to
luigi's basically someone who was in a
nintendo game that's the name of the
pizza place that you're going to go to
that would be the same thing if you're
in jersey something like that but pizza
hut is a pizza chain i get it it's
throughout the country and uh they're
really into the drag queens these days
take a look at this
this is a tweet to commemorate pride
month pizza hut is recommending books to
children about drag queens this is from
the post-millennial
and you can see bigwig
by jonathan hillman who i don't know who
he is
that is one of the books that pizza hut
is now recommending because as you get
your crappy generic pizza with their
cheese filled crust which nobody does
anyone like the cheese filled crust it's
enough it's enough already right uh you
know you really want to also learn about
gender and sexuality and cross-dressing
and drag queens from your fast food
pizza place
in sanity but i've got more insanity
we've got another one from the
post-millennial here's what's going on
over in cali
a proposed california bill to authorize
heroin injection sites passed its final
committee approval earlier this week and
heads to the state assembly this is what
is happening across blue states and blue
cities all over the place we showed you
last week that uh that billboard in new
york city and the subway where they're
basically promoting heroin they're
basically saying hey if you're on heroin
don't feel guilty about heroin just uh
make sure you're doing it okay do it
safe right and here they're gonna put
more heroin sites in california
california the [ __ ] which i fled los
angeles the dump which this guy fled and
this lady fled uh daphne by the way is
in studio today michael and
michael and phoenix are they're both a
little under the weather i don't want to
freak people out it happens it happens
it's ok i'm not going to force them to
be injected with heroin or a vaccine or
anything else hope you guys are doing
well
but my entire team fled that craptastic
place because of the heroine that was
everywhere because of the needles that
were everywhere because of the homeless
that was everywhere because of the crime
that was everywhere and the shooting and
the garbage and all of that stuff but
they just want more and more and more
and more